Charles good afternoon to you we had a
chance to meet up with El Paso's
democratic congresswoman Veronica
Escobar and she tells us impeaching
majorcus in her opinion isn't going to
solve anything she says it also wouldn't
Force Congress to do its job and find
Solutions here at the border on both
sides of the aisle she says one solution
would be to get more border patrol
agents physically out on the front lines
doing the jobs they signed up for and
less of them doing all this humanitarian
and Social Work case in point take a
look at this photo given to us by a
border patrol Source in Eagle Pass
showing a border patrol agent taking
care of a young unaccompanied migrant
child who showed up at the border
without his parents border patrol agents
have to do often have to do this play
the role of a babysitter and that takes
them off the front lines take a look at
the second Photo Tucson Arizona sector
same thing another border patrol agent
having to take care of young migrant
children it happens with single adults
as well take a look at this third piece
of video Eagle Passover the weekend when
these large groups of migrants
surrendered a border to patrol and turn
themselves in you can see what it does
to border patrol resources they've got
to respond with a bunch of agents and
remember these are highly trained law
enforcement Personnel who signed up to
patrol the front lines of the Border go
after the bad guys go after the gotaways
go after the Smugglers instead so many
of them are constantly doing paperwork
processing data entry and aren't able to
go after the runners and congresswoman
Escobar tells us that is one solution
she's proposing she says everything
Republicans have offered so far simply
isn't going to work take a listen we've
tried it the Republican way which is
addressing migration and immigration as
a border only policy it's expensive and
it's been a failure the the plan to
attempt to impeach the secretary doesn't
get us any closer to any solutions it
doesn't offer any tangible results and
despite her criticism for those
Republicans representative Escobar went
on to tell us that she is willing to
work with Kevin McCarthy and House
Republicans to find some areas of
compromise on this border crisis which
continues to get worse and worse each
month we continue to see those numbers
she also told us she would like
President Biden to come down here and
visit the Border something he has never
done in his entire life Charles will
send it back to you Thanks a Lot bill
Homeland Security secretary Alejandro
Mallorca is saying that he's not going
anywhere here to react National border
patrol council president Brandon Judd
joins Me Now by the way I do want to
mention we have reached out to the
secretary he was unable to join us
tonight Brandon I thought that was
intriguing with the Veronica Escobar
you know underscoring what I've heard
from you and so many others down there
trying to do this job being deluged that
President Biden himself needs to come
down there I mean this is a Democrat
who's saying you know the
commander-in-chief needs to come down
because two million people in the last
fiscal year illegally entered this
country
yeah she's absolutely right she was
right on two points she was wrong on a
lot of other points but she was right on
two points we do have to get more agents
out back out in the field to actually
patrolling the Border I just worked a
midnight shift the other night and I was
uh transporting I am by far the most
senior agent at my particular station
and every single agent was doing uh
administrative duties whether that was
processing whether that was a transport
whether that was detention security we
were all doing administrative duties
rather than actually out there
patrolling the border and what that does
is that creates gaps for criminal
cartels to cross their higher value
products or even cross more people into
the United States that are trying to
evade apprehension so she is right that
Biden doesn't need to come down she is
right that that we need to get more
borbital agents out on On the Border
where she's absolutely wrong is we have
had Solutions in the past remain in
Mexico was the biggest solution that I
have ever seen in my 25-year career we
drove illegal immigration down to
25-year lows we were able to go after
the cartels we were able to go after the
drugs there were a few amount of drugs
on the streets then I can remember in my
career during that during that
particular time it should be no surprise
to anybody that the the drug amounts of
drugs on the street today corresponds
with illegal immigration cartels know
exactly how how they get their higher
value products across the border and
they use illegal immigration to
facilitate that traffic so now you've
got title 42 potentially going away
what what's it going to look like what
will it potentially look like I mean
it's already a chaotic
Unstoppable scene how much worse is it
going to get
well let's be clear we would have never
in our in our worst nightmares uh been
able to imagine that things would have
been like like it is right now we would
have never imagined that we would be
pulling um 90 of our resources in any
given area out of the field
um to do administrative work rather than
patrolling the border and if if when
title 42 goes away if this
Administration does not give us any new
policies programs or operations we can
expect to be pulling a hundred percent
of our resources out of the field so
whereas cartels control certain
stretches of the border right now
they're going to control the entire
border and that's just not what this
Administration should be doing for the
American people for the protection and
security of of the United States
Brandon do you think uh secretary
mayorkas should resign
he should he should all you have to do
is look at the performance um we should
judge everybody off of performance we
should not judge them on their political
party we should not judge them on their
on their personal preferences we should
judge them strictly on their performance
you have to remember I supported his
confirmation I thought that he was going
to be a good secretary I was very wrong
um he has done absolutely nothing he
continues to deflect on all the problems
he continues to use rhetoric we try to
operate in facts if he would operate in
facts and he would tell the American
people the the truth that would be one
thing he doesn't do that and his
performance has been astoundingly bad
and based upon that performance he
should step down what would you like to
see if he were to ever step down or or
were replaced what's the key the key
characteristic or job performance you
want to see from from from that position
we want to see somebody that's going to
going to come up with Innovative
policies and programs that's what we
want if if we can look think outside the
box and and recognize that there are
ways that we can control
um illegal immigration and we can even
operate within the White House's um
parameters um if if we had a secretary
that would do that we could get the
border under under control and again it
doesn't have to be Democrat it doesn't
have to be Republican we just need
proper policies and programs it's been
going on far too long but thank you so
much we always appreciate when you come
on thank you so much hi winner Brian
kill Mead I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now